[موسيقى]
ذلك ثلاثه عوامل اثرت على الوضع الحالي
للمياه بالعراق منها سياسه الدول الجوار
المائيه واعني بسياسه دول الجوار المائيه
تركيا وايران انشات مزيد من السدود مزيد
من الانفاق لتحويل المياه مزيد من القنوات
الجانبيه ايضا
وقطعت مجاري اكثر من 56 نهر على سبيل
المثال يرفد دياله بالمياه همم انشئه
تركيا سيد اليسا وهي ماضيه في انشاء جزره
وهو سدر كثيرا على المياه داخل الحوض دجله
في العراق سيخفظها بحدود 60%
التقينا بالمستشار السابق في وزاره
الموارد المائيه ظافر عبد الله ليحدثنا عن
الاتفاقيات الدوليه خاصه الاتفاقيات التي
تنظم المياه بين تركيا وايران والعراق
واكد على وجوب ان تكون المسائل
الدبلوماسيه ومحاولات التفاوض مع الجارتين
المسلمتين ايران وتركيا
بضمان حصص عادله ونصف
للشعب العراقي
دجله والفرات
وايضا ان يرتفع ملف التفاوض هذا الى اعلى
مستوى اعلام وما هو علينا الان وان
يرتبط مع
سياسه الحكومه العامه
بالعلاقات الدوليه والعلاقات الدوليه
القرار النهائي بيد السيد الخامس
اللي هو على سلطه في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه وفي تركيا بيد السيد همم
اردوغان اللي هو رئيس الجمهوريه
بالعراق
لم يرتفع على هذا المستوى
[موسيقى]
هناك يعني
معاهدات
[موسيقى]
يعني تشاطئ على النهار في كل العالم لكن
هذه الامور نسفت من قبل الجارتين الحقيقه
وان نحن دعونا كالجنه زراعه ومن
برنامجنا ضمن عملنا في هذه اللجنه الى
تشكيل
لجنه عليا هي علياء
لاداره الملف المائي وهذا الملف يجب ان
يكون فيه متخصصين في كل الجوانب يعني
متخصصين في موضوع المياه والتخصصين في
اقامه السدود متخصصين باقامه المعاهدات
يعني يكون متكامل يعني من وزاره الخارجيه
ومن الموارد المائيه وهذه الهيئه او
اللجنه
يعني كيف تسميها اا لاداره هذه الازمه ان
تكون ثابته غير متغيره كي لا تتغير يعني
وتتاثر في الاجواء السياسيه همم اللي تحصل
في البلد اللي ربما عليها مؤثر من هنا او
من هناك همم تكون للجنه فنيه لجنه عراقيه
وطنيه
تتحاور مع الدولتين همم على هذا الشان